any change in trajectory was just a
moment
dealing with life's situation and stop
blaming the world for your unhappiness
happiness isn't something we're not a
victim of it it doesn't just happen to
us you know
it's it's happening all the time yeah
and all i mean it's just telling myself
a different story about that place where
it hurts so bad you know where before it
was like surviving it and now it's like
this is so cool we made it here and now
we we work
we have so much influence you know all
you have to do is care all you have to
do is show up half of it's showing up
right life because no one allowed me to
stop so i felt like i had to continue to
run if i would have stopped sooner i
would have healed quicker i would have
won and this is very powerful it's
transformational even if you're a
materialist this main teaching can
transform your life
interrupting the patterns of thought and
behavior that are holding you back and
pushing yourself to take action or to
think something different it is the only
way you are going to change and this is
a tool that's going to help you bridge
that gap
you